but I turn to the phone line right now
and I find a guy who I'm thrilled to
call a great friend he's a great human
on this planet he's also pretty damn
good at what he does professionally from
Fox Sports Jay Glazer how are you Jay
well you got a lot of people who respect
you Jay come on down come on how's
everything in your world are pretty good
everybody good talk about others holding
reality no problem okay I'm gonna want
to turn my back on it so you know I'm on
Fox Sports Radio right look I work for
Fox I don't work for Twitter Johnny so I
don't you know if I could say something
Fox I go Sunday that's not a job or a
show that I'm gonna do I have to or
whatever show I'm doing so on Fox work
buddy here's where the confusion comes
out I'm on Fox Sports Radio the other
night and the guys are joking around
which I look and I love the guy's a mama
a Jason Smith those guys I love but
they're joking around and I'm trying to
tell them what's on the show the next
day we have a great job on Fox football
now Shawn McVeigh and Jonathan teller
who is oh my god dude I love that kid
love that kid he's gonna be a tremendous
professional Jake I gonna be he's gonna
make some team very very happy with his
running ability from Wisconsin but I
think you're referring to Brian Allen
your ear what he's gonna bring that
locker room also manager I Great God
that had you know that offers to go to
Yale Harvard Princeton he's way smarter
than us I didn't know how to spell Yale
and so and then I was having one of our
MVP here was the week come on there John
Fullmer to give a just every week we're
having a different hero on to one of our
combat vets to give a little little hope
through this battle so the guys like
joking around I'm like no guys I have
something serious tomorrow I'm breaking
you know I was serious national movies
and I'm breaking which is national news
I said I'm his new smart and they're
joking I'm serious this is big I'm I'm
I'm just trying to get them not to laugh
because they don't know what it is right
so I'm like no I'm serious there's real
national news tomorrow and well they
just took that
heart and put it out there well I gotta
sleep and I wake up yesterday morning
literally 200 chests all 32 teams owners
players the ex players coaches wives
what's your big news what's your big
news everybody
what tell you people talking about right
maybe we already we filled in the show
the day before I could I talk to Brian
Allen about it tell him what I want to
do so he agreed to do this for me for a
show right okay that's what we talked
about not me tweeting out of news so ok
no problem and then I was gonna have
Sean McVeigh on I already had him
scheduled so it's that was just ironic
in court stencil so Brown was good with
that so I'm like cool so I can't put it
out there like he and I have agreed I'm
putting on this show anyway people are
calling what's news news and I'm like oh
dude nothing like you guys are fakes I'm
telling people so then I see people
putting up like here in Milwaukee a
Twitter poll question what is Jay
Glaser's breaking news
so I even tweeted out no so it's not
what you think it's not the
transactional news not a trade or a
player sign somewhere but it just got
ignored so again I still can't I'm
thinking man they would you put this out
but I work for a show right and I'm not
on Sports Center we're at 365 24 hours a
day right I work for a certain show fox
that's who I work for
right and that's a Brian agree to do
this interview for and which is again
you know plays it's it's all good right
no no choice look look I mean that's
just the way that one went and you know
those things happen and you know your
your heart is always in the right place
Jay and I don't think that's ever ever a
question certainly people who know you
know that so let me just put that out
there
let's get into is that is he okay I mean
how is he how is he doing and just does
he know does he know what were you got
right see you guys
what happened was he asked he lost
happiness you lost a sense of smell and
joy working is using smelling salts and
couldn't smell them now think about that
those in a fight game forget L if L get
you back a cup writer you get game to
clear your head nothing zero and then he
said doctor said that may not come back
to like eight months then he lost his
sense of taste and still you know the
only case he only feels texture of food
and he said then the flu came in and it
was unlike any other smoothies ever
experienced and said look I was
concerned because I've happened so I got
nervous but thank God he came to the
crazier part is that he tested for it
and then went back and retested last
week and just a positive again so they
had a way for him to have be symptom
free and I think today or tomorrow he'll
be seven days symptom free articles
wouldn't need to be and once he's back
and he's clear well the other part of
this which is that these and people
probably don't know this it's part of
the story that team facilities have
actually been opened for medical
purposes and so if you're a player
that's going through rehab and recovery
you can go there and the team doctors
and trainers to work with you when this
happened grams immediately had to shut
down everything in quarantine their old
that facility so guys getting with rehab
they couldn't get the rehab anymore but
I believe there now scheduled to reopen
on Monday so they've been shut down to
the last couple weeks as a result of
this so this was you know this was a you
know unfortunately you know I I wish
that original treat didn't go out in was
just my I words and that's or that I'm
you know apologize about that tweet
being sent out you know what I was good
at but it was big I want the people I
was trying to get people to understand
really the seriousness of it but then it
just took on a life of its own man and
that that that you know again I don't
work for Twitter or work for Fox know I
know
I don't wait smoke them out Jay Glazer
here on the Rich Eisen show Jay if
you're like me and I think you are queer
from similar neck of the wood
if you're pacing around your phone cuts
out a little in and out if you're
walking around your room and I want to
make sure that I got people just call
them through I'm so that's all good okay
actually oh good
and I want to get to do I want to get I
want to get to the MVP stuff for sure
but real quick the story of the draft
one week from tonight is going to be
what like what's your prediction what
are you hearing about to the point where
this you think will be talking about
this come Friday morning of next week
J I don't know what the answer to that
question is what's about what are the
questions about him but what about the
questions about him do you think they're
real or do you think this is a
smokescreen to make sure somebody is and
hop up in front of maybe the Dolphins or
something like that well all you need is
one team's not yeah to be totally fine
with it
um but when you're dealing with the hip
look Patrick four homes when his knee
popped out and just located yep it was a
perfect dislocation perfect in a very
very imperfect situation and with it
what I mean it's perfect nothing none of
the bones broke nothing cracked nothing
not even little fragments came up
there's a little ligament tear but that
was it and he still had a 10% chance of
we were doing that and to uh how to go
into the surgery I'm still so it wasn't
any perfect you know dislocation listen
he's so talented where teams may say
he's worth the risk and gamble and
encounter wise progress you've got to
hope that it doesn't happen again and
and yeah I don't really know the answer
that question because every team doctors
will probably look at it differently but
because of this foreign team teams
haven't been able to really come in and
vocally pride like they wanted so I
don't know how that's gonna check in I
don't know the answer that do you think
he's out of the top ten potentially or
know somebody no I don't know the answer
I really don't know the answer it does
everybody's all over the certain teams
is in know we're gonna put Herbert over
because of the hip and on the TV saying
no they like to us so
I don't know the answer to it Jay Glazer
here on the Rich Eisen show let's get
into what you're doing it's 70 I think
we had a different situation where
everybody be able to bring him in and
hole and poked and prodded this and that
then you'd have more of a clear-cut
answer on it well what do you say that's
the reason why what do you say that's
the reason why cams on sign right now a
larger they want to be able to see that
foot in the shoulder and does that
affect both things that he's good he's
good at without a doubt
that's why cameras outside let's talk
about what you're doing now at 7:00
Eastern Time tonight Jay you know please
this is this is why this is why we we do
or do you do what you do okay you're
very special doing this thing certainly
tonight emerging vets and players is
special nationwide session for first
responders I give you a few minutes here
about what this session is and how
people can can be a part of this tonight
certainly if they know a first responder
or if they are a first responder out
there checking us out right now Jay
those who don't know our conversation I
started years ago my partner
Nate Boyer is Green Brand X G hawk
called merging veteran players MVP we
take former combat vets emerging
together with former pro athletes
because they both look up to each other
just to give them a team again through
the transition because the transition
sucks it's awful when you don't have
your tribe and we're building these guys
a new team again so every week in five
cities we work out together for about a
half hour just to give you a burn but
then we have a mental health huddle and
we talk each other up about why you yes
transitions bad but you should not put
over in your mouth there's 22 vet today
that kill themselves that is not okay
not okay and our job to make that number
zero thank you my best friend God
Almighty that our number of MD peers has
been zero since signing up for MVP when
I think over 60% of ours attempted
before they met us and it's the way we
coach each other up and talk to each
other and we've brought people up
through from homelessness we brought we
brought people through some really a lot
of sobriety
the issues you guys have seen that we've
got an open Smith back of it hopefully
back then I felt the time of the
catalyst he's worked on the sobriety
issues with our vets and we're really
doing a lot of great things you know
Ryan Leaf is part of us we've done great
things and what we do best is work
service to other people the only thing
that gets me through my own depression
anxiety Rich's wide start these
charities could I have severe depression
anxiety is being of service to other
people
otherwise I'm always in the gray the
only thing that gets me to see in the
blue so once this this virus happened we
were the first ones to shift and went
right into zoom within 48 hours because
our veterans started saying you know
threes come with us not to isolate and
now they're making us isolate and Nate
and I were on 24-hour suicide watching
people for those first 48 72 hours RuPt
and thank God Almighty we haven't lost
any of them because we immediately went
to zoom last night we had a session with
90 people on there people in the NFL
like David Andrews from Patriots and Ben
garland who's on a visor eboard hoist
Gracie was on their Chip Kelly's on
their like it's great and then we had a
bunch of really badass combat vets well
because we're used to being of service
we decided to shift gears here and today
like you're saying 7:00 o'clock Eastern
four o'clock Pacific we're holding a
special MVP for first responders for
doctors for nurses EMT anybody who is on
the frontlines battling this coronavirus
who just needs a break we got your back
we are here for you and if you go to our
website call to action right now go to
vets and players vets and players or
sign up we'll do the same thing though
we'll have about 15 of us on help you
through loss therapists on for you Randy
Couture you know Hall of Famer MMA maple
or myself will be leading it
what's you therapists with a bunch of
other vets Kirsty Ennis who got the Pat
Tillman award this year who's one of our
combat vets at the ESPYs she's had 45
surgeries after her Ella copter went
down in Afghanistan she'll be on with us
also she's certainly
weren't able to help people through
trauma so we've got your back we're
there for you we have 300 slots open so
please come and join us it's a half-hour
workout from wherever you are and it's
not a hard workout it's gonna be an easy
workout it's from you could do it your
closet doesn't matter but then we sit
around we talk and you just got to get
some stuff off your chest
please come on and we are there for you
we want to give you a break and we will
do this weekly until you guys will throw
it fats in players org J you're a
special human love you brother
love you well thank you buddy love you
right back at you we'll chat soon okay
thanks for coming up thanks for coming
on it's Jay Glazer Fox Sports nobody
like him nobody like him again vets and
players org it would be very special and
there's a if you want to get something
off your chest you know that there's
somebody that needs to get some somebody
off their chest that they're that
they're they got a cloud around them I'm
telling you this is a way to get the
cloud out and the cloud gone even if
it's just even for five minutes
it it it will be helpful that's in
players org make sure that you can get
one of those three hundred spots tonight
I imagine they're gonna go fast that's
Jay Glazer right here on the Rich Eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here